Android patterns for performance
Data hierarchy is an important aspect of all Android applications.
But when it comes to performance, there are right and wrong ways to do it.
My name is Colt McCannless.
Your choice of the sequence and format service provider may affect
Have a significant impact on the performance of your application.
The sequence is basically
Is the process of taking an object into memory
And convert it into a coordinated set of data
Which can be converted back into an object within memory later.
Sequence occurs everywhere, starting with sending packets
Between the server and the Android device
Sending data between two processes,
Store user preferences in the disk,
And even simple things, such as passing the current song information
To the user interface to view.
Typically, most Android developers automatically choose the easiest way to create a sequence of data,
Specifically expanding its class using the sequential class.
But in terms of performance, there is actually no worse solution to this problem.
Integrated categories, such as serializable and output output stream
Will work wonderfully in terms of functionality,
But these approaches produce great pressure on memory and programming,
Making them very slow with the current function.
For the sake of performance, you will need to avoid all that mess,
And instead switch to things like the GSON library
Which creates a faster sequence and more memory-saving results.
This is despite a big problem with GSON
Is to use the JSON format, which is known to create bloated files.
Text-based attributes such as JSON and XML tend to
To decode the programming slowly and create longer results.
The current problem is that this garment can be read with the eye.
This means there are too many lengthy formulas
Which are added to the file to facilitate readability and usage.
It also tends to be super flexible,
Which means that you can easily change the order or data.
But this also comes at the expense of having additional data in the file
Which you probably do not want to actually send to the user.
Here's a quick note, that is, Android resource files
In XML format that does not have any of these issues.
It is assembled at the time of creation in a more compressed format
Provides more memory and faster loading.
So there is no need to worry about any of these problems.
So when it comes to sequencing,
You will need a faster codec that produces files as small as possible.
Fortunately for you, we have three great options available.
First, the Google Protobuffs Library is highly appreciated
Because they format the sequence is very compact and flexible.
The downside is that Java implementation of the library
It produces pressure on memory and code size,
This is not ideal for mobile software development;
This is why the Nano Proto format was created.
It is basically a Protobuffs
But optimized for Android software development, with fewer memory allocations
And fewer calls to methods
And generally less code pressures.
But what I personally prefer
It is of course the Flat Buffers Library.
This theme has been created by one of Google's game development teams
It focuses on performance.
In fact, when it comes to file size,
You can see that Flat Buffers produces smaller files than Protobuff.
When it comes to programming times and decoding,
Flat Buffers have a great advantage.
It hardly produces any pressure.
But the fact that the best solution in terms of performance
Sometimes there is no sequencing.
If you're trying, for example, to store user preferences,
Avoid storage as a sequential file.
But try using the SharedPreferences API.
It is a fast store of core values
Ideal for this type of data.
The same goes for passing data between ongoing processes.
Sequencing is still the wrong solution here.
Instead you should use the Parcelable API, which gives you a slightly sequential layout
But with a significant improvement of performance.
Although you have a lot of composite data that you plan to serialize
Do not do it.
The flow pressure of these serial organisms
Not to mention the time it takes to load
It is terrible compared to creating a local database
Using the SQL Lite API.
So everything in performance revolves around understanding the warnings
Choose the best options.
Believe me, there are warnings everywhere,
Watch the rest of your Android Performance Patterns videos.
Do not miss joining the Google+ community
To ask questions to other individuals as well.
So keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.